focus ex fait à l'époque de tata chinon
tisha cette tête à tête de chou dollars
et présentable manqua pas sonné à mater
n 6 matches 6 buts voyant peut-être
voulu être médecin car les épisodes sont
drôles ou peu son drôle tout effet le
rouge dans la petite vie et ça fait 25
ans qu'on présente parce que c'est
encore diffusée à la télévision cette
émission la plus populaire de l'histoire
de la télévision québécoise
il ya maintenant droit à une exposition
en fait il y en a eu une première
exposition présentée au musée pop le
musée de la culture populaire de
trois-rivières il ya cinq ans mais là on
a imaginé c'est vraiment une nouvelle
mouture à cette exposition la a présenté
dès mercredi au musée pointe à callière
à montréal le premier épisode de la
petite fille a été diffusé le 16 octobre
1993 il 59 épisodes qui ont été
diffusées de 1993 à 1998 avec trois
émissions spéciales dont deuxième
spéciale de noël encore aujourd'hui
samedi soir se diffuser à la télévision
est toujours plus de 500 mille
téléspectateurs wii disponible sur
l'extra tou.tv et on a demandé à claut
munich est ce qui fait en sorte qu'on
aime encore ça aujourd'hui il nous
répond tout d'abord les situations on
s'y reconnaissaient à l'époque et on s'y
reconnaît encore aujourd'hui les
relations entre parents et des enfants
et les relations de couple je vois
tellement de choses j'ai pas la preuve
de vie ni je joue un méchant qu'elle
continue parce que les gens m'en parlent
encore autant qu'au début mais la petite
vie pour moi est encore présent beaucoup
beaucoup dans ma vie mais les gens
disent toujours trahi je la connais et
lison c'est ma belle-soeur rénale
c'est mon frère mon mari ces teams et
pilotes jordan tout et vous êtes-vous
moment depuis si elles sont d'ailleurs
là d'expulsion de poète acadien yvon
artistes de personnalités pour savoir à
quel personnage on ressemble mais c'est
là c'est l'identification que les gens
font que la petite vie qui me fascine
je sais pas j'étais chanceux j'ai touché
exactement quelque chose là et l'autre
raison selon claude meunier pourquoi on
aime autant se tirer là c'est la qualité
du jeu des comédiens des comédiens qui
ont donné encore plus à leur personnage
que ce que pouvait imaginer que l'omni
en créant ces personnages la commune i
lui-même ch thériault qui a quitté la
vie publique mais qui mémorable dans le
personnage de moment marc labrèche josée
deschênes diane lavallée mark messier
guylaine tremblay rémy gerra et
plusieurs autres sa part de timmy qui
est un acte qui est bouillant et qu'il
fait réagit tout le monde s'y met
toujours tellement comme ça il peut
exploser à tout moment ça polarise du
tout le monde alors moi c'est parti un
peu de soi mais tranquillement les
personnages ont pris la place les
comédiens ont beaucoup apporté aux
personnages mais je me suis forcé j'ai
pris des mois toutes les choses que
j'étais un coup je commençais écrit je
vous écris pour les comédiens alors
j'entendais les comédies puis comédien
beaucoup amené un des comédiens
c'est comme guylaine tremblay a amené
beaucoup d'émotion au personnage de
carouge avait pas écrit aussi émotive
que ça j'avais écrit rebelles et puis
pseudo revendicatrice mais elle est
devenue vraiment revendicatrice pluies
d'une intensité incroyable comme dit
notre environnement et ans salue jean m
mais le gain crée des personnages
compris de l'intense vie malgré lui
laissa exactement et à qui on me dira
beaucoup d'anniversaires à célébrer et
donc parce que l'année prochaine c'est
les 40 ans de brouckère eu droit à une
nouvelle distribution va bien tout
souligner aussi les 40 ans du nombre de
pièces importantes les voisins que
tomomi a écrite avec louis saïa il y
aura d'ailleurs une nouvelle mouture de
cette pièce là l'année prochaine à
drummondville et les 25 ans de la petite
vie alors qu'est sentiments ça ça fait
naître chez tourner meunier de la
nostalgie au plus tôt de la fierté que
je vieillis je prends de lange en même
temps que mes écrits
mais je peux juste musique il ya moins
pour ça mais ça signifie aussi grand
bonheur parce que de bonnes choses
continuent à
à une cité comme ça c'est vraiment
plaisant qui sont encore très qu'elle
soit encore des choses que les gens le
goût de voir c'est surtout ça que ça
plaise encore aux gens ce qui est
formidable c'est vraiment un bonheur
incroyable
puis l'on voit en bas de l'écran
exposition les et pointe à callière à
quoi on peut s'attendre donc on nous
prépare une exposition immersive on veut
faire en sorte qu'on se sent comme un
pari donc on va s'installer dans la
cuisine on va se coucher dans le lit d
asile et en ligne relie la voiture aussi
avec mon téléviseur sur le capot donc on
a vraiment recréer l'univers de la
petite est en fait ce sont les décors
originaux et j'ai demandé la directrice
générale du musée pointe à callière
quels sont les moments forts elle dit
l'ensemble des décors de l'appartement
qui permettent aux visiteurs d'entrer
chez les paris et d'ailleurs certaines
sections qui n'existait plus dont la
cour avec la voiture et le sous sol fut
reconstruite à l'identique selon les
plats et on aura la chance comme nous le
disaient qu'on munis de tester nos
connaissances comme dans ce test qui est
disponible sur facebook la table issus
de la cuisine des pommes nisrine zaïbi
sont ceux des fleurs des petits sauts
lisent pas des bananes et cerise et des
bananes
c'est exactement ce qu'est né
[Musique]
l'obsession de l'inad à oui oui oui la
bamba à tamba te plus facile qu'un coup
les adore et on peut se rendre sur la
page facebook de radio canada pour faire
sauter cela sinon l'exposition au musée
pointe à callière dès mercredi présenté
jusqu'au mois d'avril et en reste